hello everybody and welcome to part 8 of
our flask and Python web development
video series in this video we're going
to be talking about our content
management system that we're going to
create it's going to be completely
custom and basically to suit my needs
but you can probably tweak this to suit
a lot of needs and what I like most
about at least this system is it doesn't
use very much RAM it keeps processing
extremely low and I like that so anyways
that keeps web hosting cheap and so
let's go ahead and get started so we've
got this dashboard we've got the tabs
they work that's great
but we know that to display the content
it might be kind of hard especially if
you want to change things later on or
maybe what if in our content management
system like for me for example I knew
that I wanted okay we know we need the
topics in the content management system
so this is a content management system
is just a term that we give to describe
a system that manages your content so
how are we going to deliver content in a
dynamic fashion to the user so or how
are we going to kind of organize the
stuff of our website and you have to
kind of initially you think that you
know you how you want to do it but as
time changes you maybe want to add to
the CMS okay or maybe you want to change
the CMS or you're going to certainly add
content okay so you have to kind of
think about these changes and at least
for me I knew ok the CMS needs to
organize via the title the grant well
first the the main topic that it goes
under so basics web development data
analysis okay so you've got that then
you've got the topic itself so that the
part in the tutorial and that will be
basically organized by title and then
you've got a link to that so what will
be the URL path to this and luckily as
I'll show you guys you can actually have
in the URLs for your website you can
actually have so right now you we write
it out but that's not the only way you
can do it you can actually put variables
in there
and you can put variables in there and
you can do all kinds of really cool
stuff and some neat hacks because
normally if you have an app arute and
the URL looks about the same or is the
same you will get an error but you can
actually trick it and send it to
basically two different or to the exact
sent you can have the exact same URLs
you do a lot of really interesting hacky
stuff with it maybe we'll talk about
that way at the end but anyway you can
put variables in here and you can do a
lot of cool magic so anyway I knew that
but then I also knew maybe down the line
I might want to add something like tags
so if I have a search bar and someone
says ok how do you plot matplotlib or
how do you do how you read from a CSV or
something I want to be able to be able
to search and find it and I don't want
to use like a Google search bar or
something like that so anyway I knew
that I may be able to end that later so
what I thought was the best way at least
to a basic degree would be to make a
just a dictionary okay so a Python
dictionary and you reference you know
part one part you know so you reference
the the key and you've got the values
and the values can be a list and you
reference the number of the list and you
can always make the list longer as long
as you're not using like say you're
referencing the negative first tooth
element that might cause trouble but as
long as you're referencing the positive
elements then you're totally fine and as
long as you're not doing crazy slicing
but you should be able to even get away
with slicing so long as you're reading
the you know left hand side but anyway
that's how we're going to do it so let's
go ahead and get started so we've got
dashboard we've got this we want it to
be custom how do we do it well the way
that I did it or have it at least at the
moment things might change but I have a
file that's literally called a Content
underscore management PI and you're
going to want a proble it's just out of
space and save it so it shows up here as
time goes on you're gonna want like you
could put everything in the init dot pi
file and I people get angry at me
because I stuff a lot of stuff into a
single file and that just really irks
people I get it I understand it doesn't
work me as much but when you're making a
website it's really easy for the init
dot pi file to get well over thousands
of lines
even like 20,000 lines is not uncommon
like you're gonna probably write about
20,000 lines of Python code for a you
know a basic to medium ish kind of
website with a lot of you know custom
dynamic stuff that's a lot of lines to
contain all within the init I file so
what does I mean to open up a second one
so anyway you to an extent you want to
separate these a new content management
was going to be a really long dictionary
so I wanted to go ahead and make its own
file so anyway content management it's
going to be real simple it's going to
have just this this dictionary for now
at least and so I'm going to define this
function of content no parameters and it
is going to have within it a topic
underscore dict and it's gonna be a
dictionary so let me move this over in
fact let me make the font size a bit
bigger so everyone can see so we've got
topic dict it's an empty dick for now
but let's say okay for our first key we
have basics with a capital b colon and
basics is going to be a list of values
but it's actually going more than that
it's going to be have to be a list of
lists for the variant for the following
reason so basics let's say the first
tutorial let me pull up Python
programming document so let's go start
learning and then here's the basics we
know we've got okay the first title is
Python introduction and but we have like
obviously this here but in fact let's go
if statement let's just use if statement
so the other ones a little different
anyway uh if statement uh so well I was
start with father I hate to start with
this statement on this video anyways
whatever we're just say it's the title
is introduction to Python programming so
you have the first element here is
introduction to Python let's just say
Python for now so that's the title and
then you're going to need the link to
that which will be basically this right
here so you'd have that's the title
that's the link let's just fullscreen
this and then that's basic
it as far as the first let's say
tutorial but then let's say we've got
another tutorial within the basics so
you have that you've got let's go to the
next one next tutorial print function
and strings and here's another reason
why you want a content management system
what if for example we go here we go to
basics and we see that first we had and
we have installing modules that's an
original that came with the series in
order but then as time went on pip is
now the preferred way to install a
package I needed to inject that tutorial
after installing modules if this was all
hard-coded not only would I have to UM
you know basically stuff this one in
there in a pretty hacky manner also at
the bottom of every tutorial we've got
buttons that lead to the next tutorial
and these buttons are actually generated
dynamically so the link that they
reference is dynamic and then the title
on the button is dynamic and so that lee
lets me basically just all I need to do
is edit this topic dictionary and add
one thing into the init dot pi file and
that's it that's the only change I have
to make it's very simple and so and then
same thing if I want to change the title
I can just go to the topic dict change
the title if I want to change the URL I
just come in here to this content
management file change the URL
everything else is done so you don't
have to worry about you know normally if
you change the URL you'd have to go back
you have to go to the URL referenced in
the ended up PI file change that URL you
have to go to every button references
change that URL you'd have to go to
basically anything that references that
so in a lot of tutorials I might say hey
check out this tutorial for more
information on how to do XYZ that would
it would just be a huge mess anytime you
wanted to change something so it's
really important that you have some sort
of content management system anyway
moving on intro to python the next thing
we have is let's just go back to in
troupe okay so intro that's this then we
have print functions and strings so we
had that so now we'll just add that one
so we'll say okay we've got print
functions
and strings and then comma and then the
URL I'll just ignore this and completed
or the question completed that's that's
for the actual tracking here but we'll
just ignore that for now but the URL
here is just this URL so spy thon
tutorial print function strings so
copy/paste done let's add one more and
then we'll be we'll be done with this
example anyway so then we got math
basics with Python three let's just copy
and paste that'll be faster huh oh
whoops what have I done
okay so brackets comma this math basics
with Python three and then we'll take
this URL copy paste okay so that's the
basics then again now if you'll this
closes off the values to the basics key
so now if we wanted to add another topic
we would just add comma enter and then
what would be the name of that next
topic I think recall we did web dev so
web dev let's just say and it will equal
something for now it's an empty list
we'll come back to that so content
management it's a Python file every time
we edit a Python file what do we need to
do we need to restart apache we're going
to come to that in a moment but for now
let's just save the content management
and we'll move this over here for now
minimize this and then we're going to
come right here and at the top of our in
an init dot pi file we want to import
this content management and we want to
import content especially and actually
let's make this content with a capital c
moving this back over now we're going to
say since it's in the in our directory
we just have to say from contents
underscore managed means imports
contents then all what we want to do
near the top of our script is basically
we'll just do it right here we'll say
topic underscored it equals contents and
let's say that we forgot to actually
return content so we'll come back over
here and this content function needs to
do something so
it's going to literally just return
topic underscore dicks save that move it
over move that up now we've got topic
dict now we need some way to transmit
topic dict to our actual HTML so it will
list it out here how do we do that well
we'll come down to dashboard render
template and then in render template you
can add some more parameters here and
one of the parameter well the rest of
them are just going to be parameters
okay or values so for example we can say
topic underscore dict
equals topic underscore dict now I
always write it this way to keep
variable names and objects which you can
Pat you can pass all kinds of stuff it's
really cool all the stuff you can pass
through I always try to keep the names
identical but just for the just so we're
clear this is corresponding to this this
is what we're going to call it in the
HTML file so we could say GB that that's
totally acceptable it's just in our HTML
file we reference it as g hg hg okay but
i don't like to do that i like to keep
the names the same it's really easy that
way when you're looking through HTML you
recognize okay that's that variable that
came from that function and you're not
changing the variables around it's just
a smart idea so that's it that's all you
have to do to pass variables uh now
we'll restart apache hopefully we don't
have any errors
we'll see sometimes you might have an
error in the import or something like
that
where are we not sure where the original
Hump dev thing was I've got too many
screens sometimes we have this many
screens just get lost anyway here's the
page well click on start learning we
head to dashboard it's the same page as
before but we have actually successfully
passed through topic dict
so let's go to here and what we'll do
now is we can do the following first of
all we could just simply do this so
that's the syntax for a variable is just
to curly
races we literally do topic underscore
dicks save that and come back over to
this let's refresh and here you actually
see we have our topic dick tits right
here I think that's pretty cool but
what's even cooler is that we can
iterate now through the topic dicks so
for example we'll just use literally a
Python for loops so you've got let's say
an unordered list that's totally fine
what do we do well we could say the
following so we need logic so this is
how we do logic and we know we want it
to be a for loop so we'll say for uh
we'll say 40 as in topic 40 in a topic
dict
and this is in the basics tab so we know
we want it to be basics against Python
code 40 and topic basics so that's going
to be for every topic and keep in mind T
is going to correspond to this right
here this whole this list I'm having a
really hard time highlighting this list
but it's going to correspond the list
right that list element is so you've got
you this is you've got element 0 which
is the title and then you've got the
element 1 which is our link so just keep
that in mind
so what we'll do 40 and top it ok let's
get rid of this and then we'll go down
here let's end this for loop before we
forget so in 4 and then you've already
started the the unordered list right so
now we just need to add list item so li
/ Li and then we know we want it to be a
link so what we're going to do is a href
equals and then close off the a so the
we want the title in between this so the
title was basically T zero right and
then the link to it was going to be T 1
but we need our variables so you do the
little curly braces
curly brace and now you've got links and
it's completely dynamic if we added a
changed content this content management
file here it is we change that it would
that would change this list on here we
would need to add anything more that
list or anything like that the links
work and the title works so let's go
ahead and save we've saved I don't think
we'd have to restart again but we will
just just just in case let's refresh and
now you can see that we actually have
our list here introduction to Python
print strings all that and we can also
see that if you look down at the bottom
where it'll save the URL we can click on
it's going to be a 404 but you can see
that it did indeed link us where we
wanted to go we've got the title all of
that so I'm going to cut off the video
here
and we'll be talking a little bit more
about the content dictionary we'll add
it will this add some web dev stuff and
some data analysis stuff just to
populate it will make the pages that we
need we'll talk a little bit more about
that we still need to talk about we'll
talk about 404s
for air 500s logging that kind of stuff
and we still got to talk about the users
and all that but hopefully you're
starting to see how simple making
websites really can be especially when
we get to use Python because that's the
the best language ever so anyways if you
guys have any questions or comments
please feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support subscriptions
and until next